madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues nous sommes
réunis ce soir pour débattre de
nouvelles motions de censure déposées
après l'engagement de la responsabilité
du gouvernement défini sur la lecture
définitive du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale une
fois n'est pas coutume l'ensemble des
groupes constitutifs de la nupes à
consigner cette motion faut-il y voir un
sursaut d'unité ou un regain du
leadership de la France insoumise après
de nombreuses remises en question de ses
partenaires par voie de presse
interposée bien sûr bien sûr cette
démarche de position consistant à tenter
de censurer le gouvernement après que
celui-ci engagé sa responsabilité sur un
texte s'inscrit dans l'application
stricte de la Constitution de la
Cinquième République et nous constatons
à l'issue du premier automne budgétaire
de la législature que l'appropriation
des outils constitutionnels par les
collègues insoumis et désormais acquise
pour ma part nouvelle député ayant
rejoint l'assemblée il y a quelques
semaines à peine je dois vous avouer ma
circonspection quand on comptait
d'examen de ce budget de la Sécurité
sociale en effet alors que notre système
de santé et de protection sociale a été
mis à rue des preuves depuis plus de
deux ans qu'il connaît des difficultés
structurelles je pensais naïvement que
les postures policéticiennes
s'effaceraient au profit d'un travail
constructif pour protéger nos
concitoyens des risques maladies et
vieillesse sauvegarder l'hôpital public
solidifier la branche autonomie je
pensais naïvement que les prêts que les
600 milliards d'euros qui abondent ce
budget devaient rassembler les députés
de la nation bien sûr avec des
divergences avec des désaccords mais
rien d'irrémédiable moins d'un mois
après mon arrivée je dois bien avouer
qu'il ne reste plus grand chose de ma
grandeur d’alors chers collègues vous
reprochez au gouvernement de ne pas
laisser le temps au dialogue mais
figurez-vous que je me suis livré un
petit calcul à force de motion de rejet
et autres motions de censure ce sont
près de 10 jours de débats qui auraient
pu servir à discuter du fond dix jours
pour trouver des comptes promis 10 jours
pour s'écouter
je pense je pense cela possible je veux
pour preuve la tenue des débats en
commission des affaires sociales ils ont
été plutôt constructifs chacun
s'écoutant chacun développements ses
arguments défendant ses amendements mais
visiblement le simple fait de monter à
cette tribune de s'asseoir dans cette
hémicycle semblent réveiller les
instincts partisans et rend ainsi
impossible un travail législatif digne
de ce nom
les discours se radicalisent le registre
de vocabulaire change de tout au tout
les décibels augmentent
substantiellement c'est dommage mais
c'est malheureusement la vérité pourquoi
cela parce que d'aucun considère qu'un
budget est un texte éminemment politique
et que les oppositions ne peuvent
envisager de le voter c'est le moment où
les oppositions de tout bord clament
haut et fort le rejet en fait du
gouvernement et de la politique qu'il
conduit alors s'il s'agit de trouver des
artifices en défendant des notions de
rejet préalable pour assurer sa base
militante en déposant des abonnements
d'affichage de tenant aucun compte de la
stabilité budgétaire indispensable pour
maintenir à flot notre sécurité sociale
voici le jeu de dupe auquel nous sommes
confrontés depuis deux mois des
oppositions qui se scandalisent du
recours à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution alors qu'elles ont toujours
affiché leur volonté de ne pas voter le
texte sachant très bien que la nation
doit se doter d'un budget pour l'année
qui vient et que de fait la seule
solution pour l'exécutif est d'utiliser
cet outil l'écrit d'orfray sur le
passage en force du gouvernement sont
vains chers collègues vous êtes à
l'origine du chaos législatif dans
lequel nous nous trouvons parce que
c'était votre objectif dès le départ sur
ce point vous ne trompez personne
tout cela est dommage vraiment car nous
l'avons constaté ces deux dernières
semaines il est possible de parvenir à
une Concorde républicaine dans cet
assemblée sur la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle relatives à l'IVG
défendue par la France insoumise ou sur
la proposition de loi relative au calcul
de la retraite des agriculteurs
présentés par les républicains
pourquoi pourquoi ne pourrions-nous pas
y parvenir sur le trésor national que
représente la sécurité sociale
quoi de plus consensuel que la
solidarité à travers la santé la famille
la prise en charge du handicap de
l'autonomie et de la dépendance la seule
question qui se pose aujourd'hui est la
suivante chers collègues de l'opposition
seriez-vous prêts à voter un budget de
la Sécurité sociale sur cette
législature
seriez-vous prêts à rechercher les voix
et les moyens du compromis en
travaillant avec nous en amont sur
l'élaboration de la loi
infini seriez-vous prêt à sortir de la
posture de l'opposant pour le bien de
nos compatriotes il s'agit pour cela de
placer ses intérêts politiques après
ceux de la nation ce n'est pas chose
aisée j'en conviens mais c'est tout à
fait possible et nécessaire
notre groupe des modes craft a par
exemple émis un certain nombre de
réserves sur le contenu de ce PLFSS pour
2023 il a obtenu gain deco sur certaines
je pense notamment au disposition
relatif aux médicaments à
l'assouplissement des conditions du
cumul emploi retraite des médecins mais
en responsable et mais pas sur d'autres
mais en responsabilité il considère que
notre pays doit pouvoir se doter des
moyens permettant aux assurés sociaux
d'être protégés c'est cela l'esprit de
responsabilité
et c'est ce à quoi nous nous
appelons chers collègues de l'opposition
vous qui vous autoproclamez défenseur du
peuple et de ses intérêts
accordez donc à l'avenir vos paroles et
vos actes à l'avenir discutons
échangeons trouvons des compromis ici
dans l'hémicycle
ce faisant ce n'est pas à nous que vous
rendrez service mais aux Français et
sans cela je crains que nous ne soyons
condamnés avoir ce triste spectacle se
reproduire encore et encore et vous nous
trouverez alors sur votre chemin car oui
madame la Première ministre le groupe
démocrate modem et indépendant veut ici
vous réaffirmer avec force sa confiance
pleine et entière dans votre conduite du
gouvernement il s'oppose donc fermement
à cette motion de censure et appelle de
ses vœux un sursaut de responsabilité de
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale pour que le prochain exercice
budgétaire puisse se dérouler dans une
ambiance de travail plus conforme à ce
qu'attendre nos concitoyens je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]